hello there my friend so we got patreon
sponsored review and I've actually got a
couple of them this month so thank you
for that that that that's a first
so mr. robot now what I was requested to
do was to cover the first two episodes
of mr. robot which is a show that I have
heard of had a general familiarity with
I knew that it's the thing most people
knew Remy Malik from before Bohemian
Rhapsody I knew it had Christian Slater
I knew it was kind of about hacking I
had a couple of friends who watched it
who said it was pretty good
I've had people in the comment sections
asked me if I watch it but I had never
gotten around to it and so I have now
seen the first two episodes of mr. robot
and I see why people like it at the very
least I see why it hooked people in
there's there's a lot that is intriguing
about it in terms of the overall
narrative of it and an Elliot as a lead
character so boy where do we start
because I have no idea if people
watching this are the folks who already
know the show on are curious about my
take or folks who haven't checked out
the show I'm trying to figure out
whether or not they want to do that so
pretty much all this is told from
Elliott's perspective and that is
something that I would expect and hope
that further on down the line of the
show becomes more directly impactful and
by that what I mean is the he's
narrating the thing and we know we are
getting very much his perspective on
that on things because of one specific
detail that starts out
early on now he works for a computer
software security cyber security company
and their biggest client is this mega
huge corporation that BC has his fingers
in everything called a Corp but he
doesn't think of them as Igor P thinks
of them as evil Corp and he mentions
early on that he kind of does a mental
filter for every reference of a Corp to
to read as evil Corp it's you know it's
like doing a convert I got it free of
there like a wicked thing or whatever
they are to like every instance of this
word replace it with this kind of thing
and what that means after we find out
that he does this every single time
another character he's talking about
this company we the audience always hear
them say evil Corp even though we know
there's no way these other people are
calling it evil Corp but that's what we
hear because we're getting it all
filtered through Elliott's
perspective and as I said it would be my
hope that that would be used to really
kind of mess with the audience a bit
because Elliott is not a particularly
reliable narrator he had well his words
were that he's schizo whether he's sort
of using that as a general sort of young
I'm kind of crazy term or whether he
actually means he's schizophrenic I'm
not sure I think he might be because
it's mentioned in his therapy session
delusions as well and a part of
schizophrenia is often both visual and
auditory hallucinations
so and he's also extremely he's paranoid
which you know just kiss friend extend
to be even if he's not schizophrenic
he's definitely got some severe social
anxiety and a lot of issues and so we
he's unreliable for that reason
in addition to that he's also got a
morphine habit which I actually don't
love like I know part of it might be to
connect him to certain characters and
that might pay off more down the road
but I feel like the there was no need to
introduce the drug problem or at least
habit start to become a problem because
by the second episode it's clear that he
is not as in control of this drug habit
as he thinks he is and that seems really
early to be introducing that as an
element because we've already got a lot
of reasons to doubt Eliot's state of
mind and thought process and I don't
know what adding drug addiction in on
top of that actually accomplishes it
strikes me as the kind of thing you
throw out like halfway through a season
as an additional curveball kind of a Oh
remember that drug habit that he thought
he had under control and you thought
well maybe he does too guess what he
doesn't instead sort of introducing
right off the bat now he has this habit
and isn't really in control of it it
makes me go okay well what does that
accomplish because I've got a ton of
reasons to already doubt everything
that's coming out of his mouth so I
don't I mean again it might lead to
certain story possibilities later on I I
can't I can't know that but in terms of
narrative groundwork it seemed
unnecessary Remy Malick does a really
good job playing this part because he's
he has to be a little creepy and a
little unsettling and a little weird and
well first of all Grammy Malik
looks a little weird so tact haha you
know all respect to the guy but he just
he does so that helps and then you know
additionally he does a really good job
of showing the characters finer points
you know kind of his intensity his focus
his analytical mind and things like that
I have mixed feelings at this point two
episodes in about and about sort of what
he's doing and what the group he's
getting him volved in are doing because
I I it just kind of frustrates me when
we get sort of this idealized version of
something that in real life is never
this pretty and by that I mean like the
whole kind of activist thing like he
starts out with the confrontation with
the guy who's a pedophile and if that
confrontation is very much the kind of
thing that we idealize these sort of
activist vigilantes would do but that
are very very very very rarely if ever
is the reality of it and I I always get
that that kind of glamorization can
annoy me yet at the same time Elliott is
not a particularly glamorous character
which I think it takes the takes the
curse off that whole issue maybe not
completely but decently because like if
if he was doing what he was doing and
was the coolest guy in the room then
yeah I will probably hate this but
because he's not and not in like a
stereotypical computer hackers are
awkward dorks way which I also would
have hated but like in a way that that
feels like hopefully around a character
that that does help balance that a
little bit and you know that's one of
those things that I kind of if I'm gonna
watch this I gotta have to roll with
because it's part of the core baseline
premise and you know it can drive me
nuts when people lob criticisms at
something that is much more about you
know not being able to even work with
the concept so that whether or not the
execution was any good becomes
irrelevant so
I you know I'm just trying I'm trying to
be as fair as I can as far as all that
goes Christian Slater plays actually the
titular mr. robot he's a hacker and sort
of the leader of this group
that seems prepared to do a lot more
extreme things than Elliot has ever
really kind of done in his own dealings
with this kind of work and these sorts
of causes and Christian Slater is pretty
good for this Christian Slater is an
actor who I don't know I've never
disliked he's always just kind of been
there and he's kind of a little bit
douchey by nature but that works for a
character like this because this guy's a
little bit unsettling a little bit of a
douche and it it works especially in
terms of like that inherent smugness
that Slater tends to have you know gives
you that air of again keeping this guy
from feeling like oh well this is the
coolest guy in the room we're supposed
to root for I mean kind of making you go
I don't know if we should have anything
to do with this guy which again I think
helps the narrative quite a bit it's a
very well shot show as well it looks
really good and yeah it is intriguing as
it as it lays out Eliot as a character
as it lays out his conflicts his sort of
mental traps and tricks oh you know what
is the one thing that like I feel the
safest in genuinely criticizing it's
that his worst assumptions about people
are always turning out to be right and
by that I mean you know he I I'm not
sure he could even stop if he tried he
just tends to hack and you know online
sort of stalk people who have any
connection to his life at all so like a
girl he's known forever is dating this
guy and so he digs through his stuff and
oh look at that he's a he's a jerk who
cheats and he's kind of dumb and he
loved and he likes these awful movies
and bad music and you know and then when
he goes to his therapist he looks into
the guy that she's dating and he's
married but hasn't told her that so he's
just cheating on his wife and he never
really loved her and I don't know
there's something like especially when
you've introduced the character that you
kind of establish as being a little bit
paranoid there's something kind of
frustrating for me about having a
character like that having their
paranoia and their cynicism validated on
a constant basis because I think it's
like if I were to I don't know why I
keep thinking of this character but he's
been popping in my head the entire time
I was sitting down talking about this I
think about somebody like house from the
show of the same name who was also a
jerk and he was the coolest guy in the
room but he was also so abrasive that
you got why nobody liked him cuz he was
one of those characters that you go
you're fun to watch I would hate to ever
meet you but often times some of the
most intriguing if not episodes of the
least interactions that he would have on
that show were with people who defied
his expectations because his
expectations were always everybody's
self-serving everybody's awful everybody
lies so on the occasions where those
philosophies didn't pan out it and he
was challenged it usually led to some of
the most interesting moments and I mean
two episodes in I don't know if like
Elliott's gonna always be right about
these kinds of characters or whatnot but
it just it was the kind of thing that I
kept hoping would turn out that like for
instance his his friend's boyfriend
wasn't actually into you know this lame
mainstream stuff anyway
he you know wasn't actually cheating on
her but that Elliott was projecting all
this on to him and he believed it to be
true like that was I kept waiting for
something like that and it never
happened which concerned me a little bit
because as intriguing a character as
Elliott is if he is operating in a world
populated almost entirely by one
dimensional stock characters that's not
gonna hold up for the long haul so I
want sort of the revelation that he's
he's putting people in boxes but he's
not right uh-huh
by doing that so yeah I think I think
I'll kind of wrap it up there I don't
know if I'm gonna continue to watch it
what what I'll say is if I had watched
this at the time that it aired I
probably would have stuck with it now
it's a harder call because you know just
logistically there's just time I don't
have that that much of it free I was
only a morally to squeeze this and
because it was sponsored for me to do so
Oh which I actually do appreciate it I'm
glad I saw this but like I said I I
don't know if I'll catch up with it and
I'm also not sure I'm in the mood for
this kind of show right now but if I had
watched this at the time it started
airing originally I probably would have
stuck with it I I see where it's
intriguing in the relationship and the
dynamic between Slater and Malick's
characters are is really interesting and
I really kind of want to see how that
develops and evolve so a assuming that I
don't just never get back to it like if
I can if I can find time for like an
episode a week and I can stick with it
maybe I can I can work through getting
caught up on this but I can definitely
see the promise in the set up really
good job on the main acting roles and it
looks really good so yeah I get why
people like
and if you haven't checked it out and if
anything that I've talked about sounds
intriguing to you at all I would
encourage you to check it out give it a
look in so mr. robot first two episodes
have you seen them what did you think
about them whatever your thoughts are
drop something down the comments let's
talk about a whole bunch of stuff down
there as well because there's buttons
and there's links there's one to my
patreon there's links to merch there's
my P o box there's other stuff besides
that go check it all out or if you don't
that's okay too
because at the end of the day you're the
council I'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned